okay in this problem the velocity head
in a given 24in box sewer is 0.75 ft
determine the flow rate through the
sewer in
MGD assume the sewer is Flowing
full so this problem the very first
thing they give us is velocity head now
that's important
because we need to know
that if we want to find the flow we're
going to probably need to solve for
velocity so velocity
head equal
0.75 ft now the equation for velocity
head can be found by either searching
for the energy equation or head Within
Chapter 6 of the reference manual so
going there we can see that this equals
v^2 over 2 G where V is your velocity
and G is the acceleration due to
gravity two since we mentioned that
we're going to be looking for flow we're
probably going to need Q equals
VA and finally
three we need it in GD so there's a
chance we'll have to convert from CFS to
MGD so let's get
started calculating out for velocity
here we can
say
0.75
ft = V ^2 / 2 *
32.2
v/s
squared and solving for V will give us
6.95 ft per
second this is a good unit conversion
check because we can see that
multiplying this over to here will give
us feet squar over second squared the
square root of that is feet per
second the next step is going to
be
multiplying V * a so
6.95 ft per second times a box sewer is
24 in so it's going to
be a
twoot
height and a two foot
width so 2 feet * 2
feet and this is going to give us Q
which will
be
27.8
cubic feet per second so as we expected
if we want to get to MGD we need to do a
unit conversion so let's do
it
27.8 ft cubed per
second
times
oops
seconds in 1 minute times
Minutes in 1
hour
times 24
hours in one
day
times
7.48
gallons per cubic
foot
times 1 million gallons
over 10 to the
6 gallons is the way I think this makes
sense to write it out so that way all of
our units will cancel cancel seconds
cancel minutes cancel
hours cancel gallons cancel cubic feet
that will leave us with million gallons
per day and plugging this whole string
into our calcul calor will give us
17.9
mg D closest answer over here is
18 and that's all it takes to solve this
problem it's worth noting that if you
don't remember the conversion
for this you can find it on page three
of the reference
manual under conversion
factors but yeah the only thing you have
to remember in this problem is that
they're giving you velocity head and you
need actually to solve for velocity
instead the rest of the problem is just
about unit conversions and solving some
basic math and that's
it